hi I'm Kevin I'll present you the work I
did during this this last four years
during my PhD Imperial College and
that's the work in collaboration with
lots of people that you can see on that
slide and go from kings and imperial so
my main goal was on automatically
finding the fittest in mr images the
quick overview of the talk i'll give
some background on fetal magnetic
resonance imaging and python for a
medical imaging and then i'll show you
the method i came up with to
automatically find the brain and then
automatically find the rest of the body
of the fittest so that's an MRI scanner
many it's a huge magnet typically 1.5
text law it's safe compared to CT or
x-rays so you can use it during
pregnancy it provides high-quality
images but unfortunately it's a really
slow acquisition process and so that's
some examples of fetal MRI as you can
see the fifties moves during during
pregnancy and imaging data text time and
so you have to deal with this and my
task is to automatic find the fittest
the problem is well if it is it's an
object in 3d and it can be in any
orientation I mean that's the bladder of
the mother so you know what the head is
there and the legs are here but the baby
can be upside down whatever and also you
can use MRI on the fetus from 20 weeks
to 40 weeks term and that's at 20 weeks
and that's at 40 weeks so you've got a
fifty percent increase in size all the
same so all the organs of the sames but
the right size the contrast patterns
things are different so that's some the
complexity I have to deal with
so because the fittest moves when we
acquire data acquiring a world 3d volume
would take too much time and the
features will move you'll get rubbish so
instead you acquire lots of 2d slices
and you stack them and you obtain so
that's the native slices and when you
stack them the you seek you can see that
the 50s moved between slices and you end
up with do the jigsaw artifacts so what
you can do is actually acquire several
stacks of 3d slices and if you can and
you can segment parts of the fittest in
those images so here we've segmented the
brain and my work has been on doing this
in an automated way months we've got
this segmented parts you can combine
them from several volumes acquired in
different directions and obtain a higher
resolution volume and you can also do
this for over parts of the body so
Python for medical imaging the nice
thing with python is that you've got
this huge ecosystem of packages and most
of those modules come with the
communities behind that can help you the
code that you can begin to understand
better it works fix it at the 3d version
if you don't have it if did not have it
yet yeah so I guess you already know
most of them the one you might not be
aware our let's say opencv everything
with your computer visions mainly C++
but automated Python wrappers VT k very
good for visualization most of you
probably know my API which is built on
top and pricing is your interface and
simple IDK which is a simplified
interface too IDK IDK being a medical
imaging a library so about let's talk
about medical imaging libraries what's
medical image it's an image but most of
the time it's 3d or 44d being 3d plus
time and with that image comes spatial
information because you want to create
you acquire different scans of different
parts of the body and you want to be
able to relate one to the other with
scanning our coordinates color
coordinates from the scanner so that you
can overlay images and when you want to
combine them and merge them you don't
start from a new start from an initial
alignment and then you can refine it so
I've been working with i Opteka in that
IDK i Opteka artist and saw the imagery
situation toolkit and why did I use that
package the main reason is i'm doing a
PhD in a lab i want to use the same
tools i'm as my colleagues most of them
don't use python but i want to use
python for let's say old images are
presented you before and other reasons
you might use the usf know the yeah so
if you use the same back end as your
colleagues then you've got the same
features the same conventions because in
medical images you've got conventions
what's left and right for instance and
you also have the same drugs and that's
important because you do hard for your
pipeline in Python suddenly you do the
second half in C++ and things don't work
anymore where's the problem well if you
were using the same back end from the
beginning thing wouldn't be working in
Python and then you would have debug
didn't you see what I mean and also I
article provide state-of-the-art
algorithm for aligning images so the way
I interface I rtk with Python was
through a seitan I did find a medical
image being a subclass of a numpy array
and with it comes in attributes which is
a dictionary holding the dimension of
the image the the orientation the origin
and the pixel size let's say one pixel
is 1 meter by 1 millimeter by four
millimeter and so I access I a ticket
through site on the benefits of doing
describing myself is that the compared
to let's say swig interface where see
Buster subjects are automatically mapped
to some pipes and stuff
the benefits of having a subclass of an
empire raised that I can overload get
item so that whenever I crop an image
the special coordinates are updated
whenever I slice it same thing and as
you see with my program of finding
organs in different block 3d volumes and
then merging the volumes together i'm
very interested in preserving those 3d
co-ordinates and you also want to
preserve those coordinates when you do
some riesling otherwise I mean if you if
you just otherwise you could just use a
scifi and the image resample but that's
the front preserve your coordinate
system so the main thing when doing this
interface between Python and sea
Poseidon was to write conversions
between I rtk and Python so that in
Python I've got mine Empire a give it to
saitun insight on I speed the dictionary
into the pixel size x axis y axis z axis
so that's the orientation the origin and
the dimension and when I speak I I speak
about the dimension that's because the
young Empire has a shape but you can
squeeze your array and remove the
flattened dimensions but in C++
everything I mean at least in I rtk it
makes simpler if everything is a 40
array so that I mean the that's much
simpler so once you've got this mapping
between a Python objects and supplies /
subject then all the rest is fed for one
on one side you write Python code on the
other side you write C++ code so now
let's talk about machine learning the
reason I went for machine learning is
what you do in machine learning is
learning from annotated examples and you
generalize from a training database to a
new subject and that way you can
implicitly model viability such as the
age or the post the photos is an
articulated body or to the background in
my case maternal tissues
compared to other problems you might
have heard of in machine learning I've
got to face the fact that i'm working on
small data sets what I'm learning on is
actually the boxers but in terms of
fetuses subjects pregnant movers Latin
beats can i only have like a 50 of them
roughly so what I did was let in fear
the size of the things we are looking
for from the age of the fittest because
we roughly know it when we scan the
movers so before you can do machine
learning the first thing you need to do
is pinned your training data set so I
had like 450 3d volumes that's because
we've got several volumes per subject
and I so I I had I i wrote a tool using
opencv to quickly both all those volume
crop my boxes and I end up with this so
that's the native slice and that's the
autumnal direction with the nori can see
the noise luckily when I was working on
the full body benefit from previous work
from Melissa de mola Ram we did a study
on a graph restriction and when she was
doing that study she manually segmented
fetuses and that's the kind of data used
in when finding the when learning how to
find that the body of the fittest as you
can see here there are striking
staircase effects and that's because she
was working on fixed slices like every
slice is separated by four millimeters
so now i present you the metal box onto
to find the brain of the fittest so
let's see that's our image and the goal
is to find the brain so I worked sliced
by slice so for every slice in your
volume I started by detecting maximalist
a barracks from all regions that's in
order I do it is not in order to please
select some regions and then I filter
the reason those regions by size because
I know roughly the size of the object
i'm looking for and then i use a bag of
birth mother so I train the next vm on
histogram of these features and it gives
me this classic
not brain brain and because I do this in
every slice I want to look and it will
do some accumulation of the votes in 3d
to obtain a best fitting place for my
bonding box and I use one sack for that
where you randomly select a few
candidates you fit the box and then you
check how many you need the rest of your
candidates fit into that box try it
several times and take the best books
you found in terms of size constraints
the way i filtered by size was using the
occipital frontal diameter and B pile
diameter which are common measurements
that are performed during a class on
examinations so but I just I know the
edge of the fittest and I know the
growth curves so that's how I get the
size in terms of evaluation so in red is
the ground truth green the detection if
we compare the center of boxes the
median a role in a tiny one I would
cross validation was a 5.7 millimeter in
in all cases we had the another lap
larger than seventy percent and if we
are asking for the hole for all of the
brain to be included in the detected box
it happened in ninety-five percent of
cases and so the runtime here for this
method is less than a minute on our
desktop PC some examples of the the
worst cases and those ones and it
happened because of the presence of the
the bladder of them over which shares I
mean similarity in terms of intensity
patterns with the CSF in the brain
seeing the liquids in the brain so now
I'll speak about the metal I develop to
find the body of the fittest so again to
be straight the problem we've got our
data and we want to find where the
bodies
so looking locally localizing the bodies
if it's a bit trickier than finding the
brain and I come just use the work I did
on the brain and trained on like change
the training data and apply the same
method it doesn't work because the
intensity patterns are different but
also because the the site at the shape
and the size are different so here
that's the brain and the the the lungs
and you can see the size difference and
you can also see that the brain is
roughly an ellipsoid the lungs are a
very a very regular shape so if you
slice the brain in whatever direction
you most of you you will always end up
with an ellipse but if you slice the
lungs you can end up with a banana you
can end up with two disconnected
components you've got something very
regular so that that's why I chose to
use a 3d approach in that case despite
the motion corruption so for these
methods what I did is first size
normalization based on the age I look
for the organs in a specific order and I
use image features which are sealed by
the anatomy of the fetus in order to
account for the unknown orientation of
the fattest so that's all fetuses from
24 weeks to 38 weeks you've got this
increase in size and we normalize the
size so if they are already segmented
it's quite easy to just stretch the
images the same way you would do with
imagemagick but given a new subject the
only thing you know is the age of the
fetus you don't know where it is in the
image so what you can use is the Crone
ramp length to resize your images so the
distance between the top of the head and
the buttocks so I said I'm looking for
the organs in a specific order I use the
method i worked on previously to find
where the brain is once i know where the
brain is i know that the hearts must be
within
a specific range from the brain once I
know where the heart is I know that the
lungs and the liver ms v within a
specific range from the heart and those
ranges i can define them independently
of the age of the fetus because of the
size normalization i mentioned before
and when you do machine learning and
images you need features you come just
use pixels like this so the kind of
image descriptions I've been using are
mainly simple difference of mean
intensities so you take one 3d patch
another 3d patch both are two random
offset from the current pixel you check
is the first patch brighter than the
second patch yes it gives you one yes it
gives you one another patch up it gives
you zero and so forth and so on and that
way you build a descriptor and that that
for this pixel this will be the input of
your machine learning algorithm and why
do we use that kind of features well
several studies show that they are
descriptive enough but also they are
very nice to work with because they are
easy to compute this can be done with
the integral image need at the integral
image is a representation of the image
where every pixel in the integral image
is the sum of the older pixel to left
and both in the original image so at one
you have the sum of all the pixel in a
in a pixel to you have all the pixel in
a and B at pixel three you have the same
of a and C at four you have the sum of
ABCD so let's say what you want is d to
have D you start by pixel for then you
remove pixel three so that you remove a
and C then you remove pixel two so that
you remove a and B that you remove the
you removed a twice so you add it again
and that way in just four
lookups you get the intensity the you
have the son of all the pixel in you
know patch independently of the size of
that patch and if you just want them in
then you just divide by the dimensions
of that patch and in 3d it's almost the
same thing it would be Nate table
lookups and in terms of Python code it's
a twist three successive course to the
cumulative sum so i said i used the
features which are still by the anatomy
of the fittest so at training time i use
features which are extracted in the
coordinate system align with deanna to
me of the fittest and that testing time
when i'm looking for the heart i rotate
around the brain and that way I know
that when I am at the true position of
the heart I am roughly in the same
configuration as a training time and
once I have accommodated for disease for
the heart I just fix the heart to brain
axis and I just have to rotate from the
mirror on that axis to find your girl
guns so the approach i use these is
based on the whole forest so it's a
combination of classification step and
regression step so first i classify
every voxel in within my range is it
hard to not hard and i get this
probability map then I do regulation
step or the vox cells that are assumed
to be hard vote for the location of the
center of the heart and that we have a
an aggregation which happens and and
then you have a much better estimate of
where the heart is so you do this for
the heart and then you do this for your
guns you've got first classification
step which is followed by a regulation
step so what I'm actually showing here
is the back projection of the relation
votes so I've got one brain location but
I formulate different candidate
hypothesis for where the heart is for
each heart I format candidate apologies
for where the lungs and liver are and
and then I optimize this the spatial
configuration
the organs so that I maximized the
detection scores and I also maximize the
score based on the relative position of
organs because the left leg should be a
to the left the right leg to the right
deliver below or this relative to the
position of the heart on the brain ittle
bit of Python code so i worked with
scikit-learn and pre computing my
features so at training time you need to
get started by your defining a selecting
a random set of sizes for your patch
test and offsets then for your lap for
all your Labour's you instruct your your
features and put them into x and y and
you loop over all your images and lastly
you you call your defeat function if you
run them for its classifier so what's
really nice with when you work with
python is that the math gets really easy
to write you write it under on your
keyboard the same way you would write it
on paper so in terms of this coordinate
system which is rotating where you've
got your current your arrays of current
pixels and you've got the brain center
so you got your current pic set here you
got your brain Center and you want to
define this rotating coordinate system
with a someone randomness in it so first
you start by computing the the vector
from the your current pixel to the brain
then you normalize it then you take
another random point you project it on
the plane orthogonal to your first
vector you normalize it using your cross
product and that's it you go to your
coordinate system at testing time well
when you expect to process your features
when you precompute them the problem is
you're working on the 3d volume so you
can't reconfigure features for all your
three volume at once
you would run out of memory so the trick
is used was by first I list all the
boxes where I want to evaluate my
classifier and then I spit it into
chunks that way have a trade-off between
memory consumption and the cost of going
back and forth between the secrets item
code of scikit-learn and the the for
loop of looking over my set of pixels in
terms of validation evaluation the I
evaluated it on two data sets the but
many the first one was more for for
training the was the one I used for
training and I the validation with was
done using leeuwen out the the second
data set is much more challenging and
it's actually corresponds the one I'm
interested in the one we use for a
motion correction and the main the key
message is that in nineteen percent of
cases in all those cases the the
detected heart center was within 10 min
ameter and that's roughly enough to fit
a box and get started with the cropping
and motion correction but the main
problem is the runtime here for that
method i end up with a 15 minutes and so
you might think oh that's a cheat you
what you wasting your time listening to
me right now especially if you heard
about the Microsoft Kinect and you say
but this guy is doing like similar of
stuff yeah i mean i'm walking i'm using
similar features and run them for us and
that's the same approach to do in
connect button connected with real time
so what's wrong with my approach and
connect they work with 2d images and
I've got 3d volumes and they work with a
fixed orientation I've got to rotate to
do this or this rotation search and but
mainly the real problem is that I've
been free computing those features and
using psychic damage is very nice
because you can apply to anything but
it's not specialized for image
processing so the first step in
optimizing my code would be to tweak the
parameters reduce the number of trees
reduce the number of features choose the
accuracy versus run time but this we
love me even after this I would still it
will t still take several minutes
so if I really want to do to be fast
what I need is a random forest
implementations which is which was built
for sliding windows so that at every
pixel you can at every pixel you have a
sliding window object which points to a
single copy of the image and your random
forest is Tom plated over the type of
points so that it can accept a sliding
window point and the type of tests so
that it can do this patch wise tests and
that way you would be computing tests on
the fly depending on your path that you
take down your trees you would compute a
different set of tests with such an
implementation which I actually used in
a different project you can do your
motif reading over the slices of your 3d
volume because if you do you're
misreading over the pixels you don't
benefit from the actual multi-threading
and well when you do start playing
toying around with the Milky training in
Python you end up with a lot of the
copying data into memory and I mean
duplicating duplicating objects into
memory and it's not that nice so some
examples of localization results on the
left side you've got the original data
and adenoids version on the right side
include hearts read the left leg Green
right now yellow for the liver so what
you see our cloud points that correspond
to the back projection of the reg
regression votes and it's a cloud and
it's not a continuous blob because
you've got those random trials so you've
got these continuities in your
prediction and the effect the benefit of
the denoising you can mostly see it when
the baby moves a lot and you end up with
those dark slices the denoising
attenuates it so it's it's actually so
it's a median filtering
so yeah and in those examples i showed
the idea is too short so that it works
whatever the orientation of the fittest
because you're doing this actual 3d
search so to conclude them I presented
you method 2 I mean submitters to
automatically find the organs of the
fittest in MRI I've done most of it
using Python finding the brain the heart
the lungs and the liver of the fittest
and I've trained only one single mother
across all ages on orientation of the
fittest and all of this I did it thanks
to the ecosystem the Python scientific
stack so from opencv i use the
maximalist every swimmer regions and the
sift features from psyche team agents i
pi and the image i benefited from a lots
of image processing functionalities from
scikit-learn i've used the support
vector machines and the random forests
and for everything i was missing then i
use seitan to get it from c++ because it
was already available in c++ so thanks a
lot for your attention and from more
information circus sauce call you can
check out my website or github
repository and if you have any question
that would be happy to take them
is the application of this so the main
application is what I presented at the
beginning you you're the fittest moves
you're crying several stacks several 20
volumes and you want to merge those
volumes but when you merge those volumes
you need to extract you need to exclude
them over from the image because the
fittest moves independently of them over
so the decision be using the information
about where you located the gray or the
DECA nishant look at an x-ray or MRI
scan because intuitively locate the
brave already so we would actually use
the what the clinician wants to look at
is also we want currently most of them
they look at slide the sliced by slice
data but also they would like to be able
to look at it as a 3d volume we slice
this energy Direction rotate it in 3d
and for this they need to do this motion
correction and for this motion
correction currently they need to do
some manual segmentation so that's where
I come in and I say hey we could do this
manual segmentation automatically
we say in instructional scam yeah I so
so that's the kind of to think very very
useful I know some I know some people in
one love i've been using its people in
my lab there's one the they've been
using it a little bit but there's
there's still one thing which is missing
which is when you work on the brain if
the fittest moves a lot does coordinate
system you get from the scanner there
they are not enough to initialize the
motion correction because if you move
too much and there's not enough overlap
between the images anymore realigning
them doesn't work well and in that case
what they do is actually manually select
some manually initializes alignment and
in that case well they don't really need
my work and like like so something which
is missing from what I did is finding
the orientation as well of the brain so
that I could help them align these
images better so they will check out the
size of different regions for m4 in
particular the Devon trickers for
instance but also a lot of this research
a lot of this is like some of this is
for clinical application but most of it
currently is for research and we do this
on heavy subjects and we're trying to
understand how the healthy brains
developed and and also once you know how
the healthy brains developed you want to
compare it to preterm babies and also
and all that's it we have any other
questions
and you mentioned that you're using you
started up looking a pilot in the
different libraries you kind of use more
sees you went through if you didn't have
constraints of the rest your lab would
you try and pull more ripped open or
what you thought lesson I would I think
the the right solution is a treadle fit
in both because I mean you can't loop
over pixels in Python but you cannot do
everything in in C++ and i would say
lots of people use fightin in my lab
just the way you would use bash they
they call lots of binaries and by python
is just too cute to hear two two two two
lists you there Feist do some pattern
regular expressions on the find names
and an open the csv file and then call
the CSC presses binaries so I mean we
need both and or the motion correction
code I talked it will ever be written in
Python and that's a pure C++ code and it
has been recently bought it to cuda and
that's I mean so you need to for
pipeline like the one I did you need
Python but for something which is very
specific then you need the unity press
press without your strategy or we still
do the same solution like the happy that
is real yes but but since I came in that
more people are switching to python
instead of matlab but we still need the
c++ behind
any more question so thanks a lot for
your attention